so there's this thing that keeps
happening with rockstar games
unfortunately happened again today a
rockstar have announced the Scranton
auto 5 on PC when they be coming out in
late March obviously was supposed to
come out and just under two weeks time
and this is sort of underscores a
worrying trend with rockstar games
because we're thinking around the office
like this people were anticipating that
this might happen forever because this
always seems to happen raksha games so I
went back inside like checking out just
some of the old delays that have
happened over the past couple years in
some digging I did some digging I did
some researching sleuthing and you may
remember that red dead redemption was
actually supposed to come out in april
of 2010 I'm ended up being pushed a
month to me 18th not that bad alright a
month same fiscal quarter yeah so let's
all I care about like that's what take
to care about yeah it's so short like
what were they dodging another release
were they like they just had to get that
one more patch in like a mulligan what
can you even do in a month especially
that I mean now you can do a lot but
back then it didn't seem like he could
really oh oh don't worry there have been
longer delays and GTA 4 for instance was
originally supposed to come out in
October 2007 and ended up coming out in
April 2008 Wow so that was almost a full
as six months again within the second
fiscal quarter in fact just a day inside
at the second fiscal quarter which
obviously makes a big deal for take two
and all of their is that their cronies
is it really the second or is it the
first of their fiscal year because some
companies oh yeah january through march
is their q4 and then the new year starts
q1 so i don't know if like a rockstar
doesn't that way but I just wanted to
it's not a wrench in the works this is
this is my fault for not having a clear
about finances really grand theft auto
san andreas was pushed back from to
october twenty sixth instead of the
original last october 19th and got
pushed back in Europe an extra week to
october 29 so again just a week even
shorter but it seems like the tank they
can't go one game without delaying
they're just gonna
seven days what if we do it will fix
that thing will take out hot coffee or
put it in man slip it in yeah so to
speak of course that game ended up
putting pulled off shelves anyway
because of hot coffee and then put back
out again and here's an interesting one
GTA 3 was supposed to come out in the
third week of September in 2001 and then
obviously because of the 911 terrorist
attacks they ended up actually bringing
it back in and removing some imagery
from the game ended up coming out on the
twenty-second of October of that year so
apparently there were specific touches I
think they I'm not sure if it's been
confirmed but there's word that they
took out some sort of aspect of the twin
towers that were in Liberty City they
also changed stuff like the M cop cars
were very much like the NYPD ones and I
think they thought that I might have
been tasteless to keep them that similar
so they change the D cause on them oh
yeah so that's that's that shows you how
far back this goes and then of course
probably the latest one is grand theft
auto heists at GTA online heists which
was supposed to come out I think June of
last year and as opposed to launch with
online but then there right now it's not
going to quite be their launch and then
who knows when it's become and then oh
it's gonna come with PC yeah version but
now I think it's been delayed four times
yeah I pro Rob handlery he does some
fantastic Grand Theft Auto features on
gamespot like every couple of weeks like
all right and do my hi CJ you're a
mid-weight so just recently god damn it
like oh it's been a delayed again poor
guy and so this is obviously something
that we've come to expect and even
though today you know a two-month delay
this close to launch anyone else would
be like absolutely insane but we've
almost come to expect it from rockstar
that's what's so fascinating to me is
you think of a triple a game you think
of a GTA you think of these huge games
that have big marketing campaigns
scheduled and you know they have so much
momentum that they swen they set the
release dates months and months years
sometimes in advance that they're all
trying to target here for like maximum
sales books success whatever and then
GTA like the history you're just talking
about like yeah let's just pump in a
week ah maybe like next month we'll do
it instead yeah you know what this fall
is not going to work for us let's just
make a next spring like
the length of the delays baffles me
because how much it varies but also I
mean I guess is it a testament to rock
star and how good their games are that
like they still sell gangbusters and no
one had no one hasn't really caught up
with the story being like oh yeah that
delay really hurt red dead redemption
yeah so the one consistent thing I think
or rockstar games and maybe you'll agree
with this or not is that eat whenever
they come out they work like they're
generally polished or they don't have
that many bugs and these are like games
with so many different systems in them
like all the grand theft autos in red
dead redemption i'd say maybe i think
one of the versions of bully was a
little bit buggy and but like these
games work so do you think perhaps it's
something to do with just they hold
quality control to such a high standard
i want to raise an exception oh yeah
grand theft auto 4 i'm pc the first few
months when that was out was horribly
optimized yes like garbage maybe they're
maybe they're just double checking their
work you know this time around yeah like
it but yeah you're right like most of
the times like for such a complex world
like these things work pretty flawlessly
so i bet you if anything they're just
yet double checking to make sure that
everything is just like watertight
totally solid and not bunk well I guess
we'll have another couple of months to
find out sadly I will be the end of
marks before we get to see perhaps the
latest mod of pool Eakins in GTA 5 or
maybe that low friction mod and I know
folks are on the consoles like who cares
you can already get it on playstation 4
xbox 360 and everything but come on we
just want to see those mods sinful okay
yeah look at the wrong hey any of you
don't have the pc to run that the mods
you got the youtube exactly the gold
there's so funny the twitch experience
on GTA 5 good see it's gonna be pretty
good